just tell me what happened next
look I don't know it's fuzzy you went up
your medication why we're just looking
for the truth which you promised to tell
I told you they took her Sydney Barrett
the girl who disappeared she didn't
disappear
she took my place tonight the curse
weapon she was her power I think can you
explain that that was a crazy or
continued he believes he's mentally ill
but he may be the most powerful mutant
we've ever encountered can we take a
break please of course
let's just take a break
stop we can skip that part unless you
think it's relevant to no no I have to
okay let's talk about it
[Music]
look at me I know what I am and what's
that and kiss the girl
she took my place and I took hers stop
would you say that again
[Music]
hey youtubers is Charlie so batshit
crazy Legion trailer let's break it down
so a lot of you are asking is this set
or is it connected to the x-men films
that Fox has in Bryan Singer like
different people have said different
things but Bryan Singer has since come
out and said yes it is connected but
it's not going to be like a Marvel
situation where they're directly
referencing everything that's going on
in the movies and everything that's
going on the TV show at the same time
but it is supposed to be connected if
you don't know who the Legion character
is Legion is the name of the character
the series name Legion is after the
character's name it's not the name of a
team so the whole pitch is that Chris
Claremont created him in the 80s he was
part of the big Chris Claremont run in
the x-men comics some of the best if not
all the best x-men stories come from him
so the whole pitch of the character is
is that you know what if Professor X one
of the most powerful mutants on the
planet had a son who was even more
powerful but he was completely crazy
what would happen so this Legion
character is born and he has like this
infinite capacity for good or evil
and he has multiple personalities each
of them possessing a different mutant
power so he's basically like this
omega-level mutant like on the level of
apocalypse or Franklin Richards or even
gene grant you know maybe not quite as
powerful as the Phoenix but you get the
idea like he's one of the most powerful
mutants on the planet but because he has
so many different personalities you have
no idea who you're dealing with not all
of the personalities are good people
some of them are villains some of them
are really big heroes so the idea to
Chris Claremont was talking about how
like people back in the 80s were like
hey you know you should put him on like
the x-men T like he should team up with
some other people and you kind of get
this from the trailer like he said he
would just laugh and be like look this
dude does not belong outside of a
psychiatric facility there's no way that
any team would want to have him like
Wolverine would just flip his [ __ ] if he
found out that someone this crazy was on
his team so in the more recent comics
they have ways of dealing with those
like you know ways of eliminating those
other personalities kind of winnowing it
down to a place where he can actually
exist with other people he can be social
so if you don't read comics like
right now in the x-men comics at Marvel
things are going completely crazy it's
almost like Marvel is killing off the
x-men they're really engineering like a
big rebirth like it's happening at DC
those are kind of reinvigorating to the
characters but before you can have a
renaissance you have to have the Dark
Ages so like they're slowly killing off
all the x-men right now so it seems like
a complete shitstorm if you don't know
what's coming Marvel isn't trying to
kill off the x-men they definitely want
to see some collaboration with the Fox
x-men universe in the movies and it just
takes time so back to the TV show you
see Aubrey Plaza here obviously like one
of the people who seems so crazy that
she might be saying like the whole idea
with this character here is that he's
completely crazy but you know but what
if he were the same one and everybody
else was crazy like One Flew Over the
Cuckoo's Nest or like Brad Pitt's
character during 12 monkeys the guy that
Bruce Willis runs into in the insane
asylum who ends up being this prophet
that kind of engineering this
self-fulfilling prophecy so like
sometimes the people in the comics that
seem crazy that you run into are really
the same people that are trying to tell
you the truth everybody else are the
real crazy people so I think that's
gonna be the twist of the series here so
like you run into Aubrey Plaza who just
has like this sixth sense about her who
just senses something different about
the légion character who befriends him
so they're gonna have some fun
adventures inside this asylum I would be
willing to bet one of the villains of
the pilot is going to be this person
called major perdition so in this TV
universe the government knows about
mutants so usually when you have
situations like that with omega-level
mutant the government or like some
entity tries to co-opt them to use them
for their purposes which are usually
really bad so we don't really know much
about the plot of the series if it's
gonna follow any comic book arcs but you
can see from the trailer he switches
places with this female character he
does that on purpose is crazy as it
seems so the trailer jumps around a lot
through his life like you see flashes
back you know as he's having this
hallucinatory dream where all of his
different powers are activating with
these different personalities I'll be
interested to see how they explain that
through this series but it looks like
it's just going to be completely crazy
which I totally love cable shows have a
little bit easier time with that use
when you hear about a new superhero
series you really want it to go to cable
so they can just play with a little bit
more they don't have to be quite as
boring as it is when it goes to like a
big network
but you see flashes of his family in
here he keeps talking about the Sidney
Barrett character that he was trying to
rescue although she didn't disappear we
switch places maybe it was her power so
you have like a mixture of like the
rogue character from the Brian singer
x-men movies who has this alienated
feeling because she keeps taking
people's power like she can't touch
people or else she'll like zap their
life force steal their powers so a
little bit of the fun of the series is
gonna be like making our way through
this fever dream that is his brain all
of these different personalities seems
really cool big action set-pieces as
like his powers activate
like think about all the different
powers you see in an x-men movie like
all the different characters powers he
pretty much has access to all of those
like he has so many different
personalities that he almost has every
single power but it's not completely
infinite and then you have situations
like I said earlier where characters
come in and start killing off the other
personalities so he loses those
abilities so it was just like a way to
keep it under control like you can't
have limitless abilities otherwise it'd
just be ridiculous
well let me know what you guys think
about the look of this series so far
keep in mind the age of the character
here so like if he's Professor X's son
in the comics we're really talking about
Patrick Stewart's Professor X just
because he's like a middle aged man so
Professor X would be much older in this
so some of you in related x-men movie
news know that the Wolverine movie just
finished shooting Patrick Stewart guest
stars in that with Hugh Jackman who's
playing like a version of old man Logan
so you have all these x-men movies
taking place at Fox the main movies are
kind of in the 90s because Sophie
Turner's Jean Grey character hasn't
become the Phoenix yet that's kind of
what they're getting ready for in the
next movie then you have the Wolverine
movies which are like way further in the
future doing old man Logan stuff and
then you have the TV shows which are
kind of taking place in between all that
stuff but it seems like it's gonna be a
lot of fun I'll at least do a video for
the first episode but it's not
premiering til early 2017 so it's still
a ways off so just let me know what you
guys think of it so far and if you've
ever read
comic book story with the legion
character really he's not that big of a
character for how powerful he is he's
not like Wolverine he's not like Jean
Grey he's not like Cyclops he's not like
one of the main x-men so it should be a
lot of fun and I'm a big fan of Aubrey
Plaza I just love how crazy she is in
this trailer usually her best
performances or when she gets to be just
batshit crazy
so when related Marvel news later
tonight I'm going to be doing an
Avengers infinity war Thanos video they
just started to shoot the movie so
purple man has left the chair repeat
purple man has left the chair it is on
[ __ ] is going down so be sure to
subscribe to get that that should post
later tonight while you guys wait for
that to post you can click here for the
flash trailer that I just posted and you
can click here to learn a little bit
more about the Infinity Gauntlet in the
actual gems in the gauntlet so thank you
so much for watching everybody let's
high five I'll see you guys tonight